What does it mean… for a world to have died?
Does it have to be desolate, does it have
to lie in ruins, or could it be beautiful,
still rich with green, still haunted by the
rare remaining lifeform?
I ask these questions, because the game Gris…
is quite possibly the most visually breathtaking
thing I’ve ever played.
The world is incredible — the colors, the
creatures, the landscapes!
It’s all so… alive.
Which is important, because I believe the
world of Gris… is a world that has died.
When we think of ‘dead worlds,’ we typically
don’t think of beauty.
This is especially true for video games — where
the word ‘dead’ usually implies a setting
is lacking in meaningful content.
But I want to challenge this assumption, to
explore environments that are spectacular
and filled with artistic merit, yet are, in
their own ways, dead.
For sometimes the end of the world is just
the beginning…
Speaking of which, Gris begins with the end
of the world.
The protagonist, living in a landscape of
color upon a mysterious stone hand, finds
this realm collapsing around her.
Falling through the sky, she descends all
the way to the surface, where nothing remains
but a monochrome, desolate expanse.
From here, the world is split into five sections
that reflect the five stages of grief.
Each region is further centered on a dominant
color, with gray representing the initial
detachment of denial.
Recovering from the fall, you wander through
a graveyard of bleak ruins — perhaps wreckage
from the recent calamity, or perhaps remnants
from an age lost to time.
The environments of Gris are not meant to
be completely literal, the external desolation
often a symbolic representation of the main
character’s inner sorrow.
The opening of Gris can be better understood
in conversation with this… other game about
personal loss personified on a vast, impersonal
scale.
Shadow of the Colossus is the kind of title
that looms over the entire medium.
The iconic story of a lone warrior defeating
sixteen leviathans to bring a loved one back
to life — the game does not, at a glance,
take place in a ‘dead world’.
I mean…
there are giant creatures wandering around
in it, hard to get more ‘alive’ than that,
right?
Yet the Forbidden Lands — the forgotten,
cursed region where the game takes place —somehow
manage to feel… blank.
The kind of blankness that hollows you out.
It takes so long to travel to each colossus
that the towering giants start to seem hopelessly
minuscule next to the bleak enormity of the
land itself.
There’s an argument to be made that this
feeling of blankness was even more profound
in earlier versions of the game due to the
limited graphical detail, but even in the
remastered version, the ‘wrongness’ this
land is unmistakable, like this is a world
that life has forsaken.
Though often beautiful, it is, in its own
way, a dead world.
But Shadow of the Colossus has more in common
with the first stage of Gris than just its
setting.
It is also, quite overtly, a story about denial.
It is clear from the opening sequence that
this deal the main character has struck to
resurrect their loved one is… extremely
dodgy.
And yet it’s easy for both the protagonist
and the player to ignore any feelings of unease,
because there are monsters to fight!
But as the game wears on, you start to think
more and more about how most of these creatures
only become aggressive if you attack first.
I’m far from the first person to make this
point, but because of the environment’s
bareness, you’re left alone with your thoughts
between each battle.
This makes it harder to hide from the fact
that you’re extinguishing some of the last
remaining beings in this world — all because
you can’t let go of a personal loss.
…If you return to a spot where you slew
a colossus, you will find their bodies have
become part of the landscape, the surroundings
sweeping in to reclaim these last vestiges
of life.
It is impossible, when exploring these remains,
to hide from the reality of what you’ve
done.
Though you, like the protagonist, want to
keep denying that the world — their world
— is really dead, the physicality of these
bodies makes the truth of bereavement undeniable.
It's not clear, at first, whom the protagonist
of Gris is grieving for.
But it is clear she is grieving for someone
who was central to her emotional world, their
significance quite literally embodied in the
colossal statues littered throughout the land.
That disintegrating hand in the opening represented
their passing, yet they stood so tall in the
protagonist’s life that their remains continue
to shape the environment long after their
death.
The way death alters the landscapes of these
games reminds me of a real natural phenomenon.
When a whale swims its last, the carcass will
sometimes sink all the way to the ocean floor
and create something called a ‘whalefall.’
The impact of a whalefall on the abyssal ecosystem
is, well, colossal.
A single carcass can bring more organic material
to the seafloor than two hundred years of
nutrients falling from the surface.
Like grief, whalefalls too can be divided
into specific stages.
In the initial Scavenger Stage, specialized
foragers pillage the leviathan from all directions.
After playing Shadow of the Colossus, I think
I kind of know what that feels like.
For the next two years, the whale’s remains
will become animated with movement — a tumultuous
new ecosystem formed from the remains of a
dead one.
The world of Gris, likewise, doesn’t remain
gray forever.
And as denial turns to anger, harsh splotches
of red seep into the surrounding environment.
You slide, emboldened with reckless fury,
down a steep slope into an unforgiving desert.
Ruins streak these maroon sands, the jutting
spires like the tips of spears left over from
some ancient battle.
Storms also sweep through this region, watercolor
swirls of blood-red that make it wise to seek
shelter.
Yet critically, the game gives you the option
to face these storms head-on, and though you’ll
inevitably be blown backwards, it’s difficult
to resist the temptation to charge blindly
forwards, and become angry at the world itself…
The game Hollow Knight similarly encourages
you to think combatively.
With its punishing difficulty and aggressive
enemies, the game makes it feels like it’s
you against the world.
Set in the fallen kingdom of Hallownest, Hollow
Knight’s ecosystem is plagued by a supernatural
illness known simply as the Infection — an
apocalyptic epidemic that manifests in the
form of rageful insects and great pustules
of disease.
The background design can make the entire
world feel like a kind of infection, an unwanted
growth upon a long-dead exoskeleton.
Yet Hollow Knight is also full of quiet expressions
of endurance, perseverance even in the grimmest
environments.
Though nominally a game about violence, I
think it’s also a game about rebirth, and
how beauty can emerge in the toughest conditions.
In the second stage of Gris, you can encounter,
in the shelters, creatures living inside chunks
of ruins.
Like the denizens of Hollow Knight, one could
interpret these lifeforms — which come in
all shapes and sizes — as infections, unwanted
parasites plaguing the corpse of a lost civilization.
But there’s also something poignant here,
a testament to adaptability in the face of
adversity, one that can help you appreciate
the value of knowing when to take shelter.
Perhaps a version of the world has perished,
but if you let go of your anger, you can see
that new life has taken root.
With the protagonist’s anger subsiding,
the world transforms in an eruption of green.
Enormous vines snake across the landscape,
leading down far below another layer of clouds
to a vast and inviting forest.
Your grief has now entered the bargaining
stage, and it’s easy to feel like your sorrows
will no longer shape the world, that there
will be no traces of decay in this landscape.
Yet even in the midst of the forest, the shells
of abandoned buildings still remain, the remnants
overrun with encroaching plant life.
…How should we feel when we see cities reclaimed
by nature?
It’s a question that was on my mind a lot
when I played Cloud Gardens, a peaceful gardening
simulator crossed with a… dystopian landscape
builder, I guess?
In this game, you help plants swallow up the
wreckage of humanity, an activity that elicits…
complicated emotions.
On the one hand, Cloud Gardens has a charming
voxel aesthetic that makes turning decrepit
cityscapes into bastions of life quite satisfying.
But on the other hand, well…
there’s definitely no sign of living people
in these landscapes.
In his book “The World Without Us,” American
journalist Alan Weisman explores what would
theoretically happen to human structures and
objects if we all suddenly disappeared.
And the answer, for the most part, is that
nature would erase all traces of humanity
extremely quickly.
Most buildings would be gone in just a few
hundred years.
Certain plastics and metals would linger a
little longer… but not forever.
On a geological timescale, our built environments
would be gone in the blink of an eye.
There is a kind of mental bargaining that
goes on when I try to decide how such facts
make me feel.
Is it comforting to know that new life would
grow from the skeleton of humanity if our
species were to go extinct?
Or is it terrifying to imagine being forgotten
so easily?
There are no other humans left in the forest
of Gris.
But there is a little robot, who you, fittingly,
have to literally bargain with to find a way
out of the woods.
It’s a sweet change of pace from your lonesome
travels.
Yet something about the way the robot knows
all the ins and outs of the forest can make
you feel like it belongs in this reborn world
in a way that you just…
don’t.
The world you knew is gone, and no amount
of bargaining will change that.
As the protagonist floats once more in the
palm of the person she lost, the landscape
changes a fourth time and the long melancholy
of sadness begins.
This stage of grief is represented, unsurprisingly,
by shades of blue.
Rain begins to fall like teardrops as you
strike out through a flooded watercolor landscape.
Yet while the surface of this region is gloomy,
if you dive under the waves, you’ll find
a thriving ecosystem of fish.
It’s a jarring transition.
How can this ‘dead world,’ a world in
the wake of a calamity, be so full of life?
I don’t think I’ve ever seen a setting
more vibrant than the one in Abzu.
A game where you steer a diver through gorgeous
undersea environments, the ecosystem is just
overflowing with movement.
I genuinely don’t even know how it’s possible
for a title from 2016 to simulate this many
schools of fish at a time.
If you just stop the camera, anywhere, the
sheer amount of marine life that will swim
by is just insane.
It’s all so kinetic, so interactive, so
full of vitality.
I don’t know that there’s ever been a
world more emphatically alive than this one.
And yet the world of Abzu is haunted by death.
From early in the game, you can stumble upon
murals from a doomed civilization.
Each fragment tells of a culture that fell,
of a people whose memory is lost to the waves,
their crumbling halls now home to creatures
of the deep.
There are ruins in the ocean of Gris as well,
sunken temples overgrown with forests of coral.
It reminds me of the second stage of a whalefall,
when groves of lifeforms known as ‘zombie
worms’ spread their roots into the bones.
They pick the skeleton completely clean, making
it hard to imagine the animal as it once was.
But there’s a moment in Abzu that conveys
the splendor of a living whale better than
perhaps any other piece of media.
It is, at first, a tranquil moment where you
swim with a mother and calf through the open
ocean.
And as you swim, an entire pod of whales joins
your dive, opening their mouths wide to take
huge gulps of krill.
And then they swim on, and you think the moment
is over — until another pod of whales, even
larger than the first, comes in from the other
direction.
Before you even have a chance to fully process
the sight — this happens.
A blue whale emerges from offscreen, its eye
right next to you, just staring.
And then the camera pulls all the way back,
and you realize you’re in the midst of another
pod, and they all start spinning through the
depths, brimming with life and majesty.
And then, at last, this pod departs as well,
and you realize you’ve accidentally traveled
all the way down to the very bottom of the
ocean.
And what you find down here is a vast boneyard
of whales forgotten on the sea floor.
It’s a real tonal shift, that can be read
as pessimistic.
But I think that would be doing this moment
a disservice, because even though these skeletons
are picked clean — that doesn’t mean they’re
lifeless.
In the third and final stage of a whalefall,
the bones appear deserted, but they’re actually
full of bacteria that produce vital sulfides
to the surrounding ecosystem.
Other forms of life can flourish around a
whalefall for up to half a century — sometimes
longer than the lifespan of whales themselves.
Maybe the bionetwork of Abzu is built upon
remains, but it is likely because of these
remains that so much life has gathered in
one place.
Even in the best of circumstances, however,
the presence of any skeleton implies a cause
of death.
For worlds, this typically means some kind
of apocalyptic event, the sort of big destructive
moment that disaster movies love to show us
in gratuitous detail.
I think it’s important, therefore, that
you never see the calamity that sank the civilization
in Abzu.
You also never learn what emptied the world
in Cloud Gardens, or made the cursed lands
in Shadow of the Colossus, you know, cursed.
Even Gris, which is about the passing of a
specific person as much as the world, never
gives us any insight into the demise itself.
In the context of these narratives, it doesn’t
really matter.
What matters is what happens next.
If any force in Gris could be labeled apocalyptic,
it would be the tendrils of shadow that haunt
the protagonist throughout her journey.
Likely a representation of grief’s most
destructive tendencies, this darkness constantly
threatens to overwhelm the main character.
Like sorrow itself, it knows no boundaries,
following you into any environment.
In one underwater section, it becomes a giant
eel that pursues you through tight corridors
in one of the tensest chase scenes I’ve
witnessed.
Like death, it seems inescapable, able to
split itself into two to cut off your escape,
or transform into a thousand little eels that
chase you into the blackness…
One of the grimmest dead worlds I’ve seen
is ‘There Will Come Soft Rains,’ a 1984
Soviet animated short film.
Based on a Ray Bradbury story of the same
name, the narrative follows the automatic
systems of a house continuing their pre-programed
daily routines, despite the fact the people
of the house are… ashes.
It is revealed that this building is the last
one standing on a planet that has otherwise
been obliterated by nuclear war.
The title for ‘There Will Come Soft Rains’
comes from a poem by Sara Teasdale, which
the house recites part of at the end of the
story: “Not one would mind, neither bird
nor tree, / If mankind perished utterly; / And
Spring herself, when she woke at dawn, / Would
scarcely know that we were gone.”
Though not exactly…
uplifting, this poem, like Bradbury’s short
story, is more tranquil than the animated
short.
I think there is a kind of comfort one can
take in this idea of nature continuing on
without us, particularly in 1918 when the
poem was written, against the backdrop of
the First World War.
The poem, and many of the games in this video,
imply that if a version of the world comes
to an end, another will take its place.
Even in the darkness, there is light.
The very last color of Gris is an illuminating
shade of yellow, representing the stage of
acceptance.
Significantly, however, this final stage does
not return the world to a pre-ruined state.
The architecture, though brighter, is still
withered and overgrown with plants.
Acceptance doesn’t mean returning to the
way things were, just recognizing them as
they are.
I don’t think any game exemplifies this
concept better than Sable, the final title
I want to discuss today.
Set within a harsh desert, Sable has, on the
surface, the most conventionally desolate
post-apocalyptic world in this entire video.
But it is not, to a remarkable degree, a game
interested in mourning the past.
None of the people you speak to are wistful
of ages gone, or lamenting the desolation
that surrounds them.
Though there isn’t as much wildlife in this
land as most of the games in this video, people
delight in the animals they have all the more.
Everyone’s satisfaction, presumably, is
because so much time has passed, no one remembers
the way things used to be.
The world has mourned, and now, it has moved
on.
Indeed, as a coming-of-age story, Sable’s
narrative is deeply focused on the future,
on what’s waiting over the next horizon.
I think it’s fitting that the largest structure
in Sable is a set of ruins nicknamed ‘The
Whale.’
Implied to have once been part of an interstellar
ship, these ruins have been pulled apart for
building materials to make new houses.
Likewise, there are theories that there is
actually a secret fourth stage to whalefalls
where their skeleton provides a structure
for new coral reefs.
Since scientists have only been researching
whalefalls for a few decades, it’s currently
unknown how far into the future this stage
could sustain life.
Is a whalefall really dead?
I mean, certainly the whale is dead — that
original lifeform will never swim again, no
matter how positive we want to be about its
role in the circle of life.
I don’t want to trivialize the idea of a
dead world.
Not all these games leave you feeling uplifted,
and not all of them should.
Acceptance isn’t about feeling happy forever;
it just means an acknowledgement of a loss.
And for all their beauty, these worlds are
tragic; there is grief here, just as there
are moments of delight.
These worlds have died.
And the world lives on.
And as always, thanks for watching.
If you enjoyed this entry, please lend your
support by liking, subscribing, and hitting
the notification icon to stay up to date on
all things Curious.
See you in the next video.